el puerto Jiménez de aludida recibió
este sábado tres buques comerciales por
primera vez desde que estalló la guerra
en 2015 el puerto controlado por los
Rebeldes uchis atendía El 75% de las
necesidades de la población de yement
Sin embargo era inaccesible desde que
Arabia Saudita que apoya al gobierno
central con una coalición de países
impulsó un bloqueo sobre las zonas
controladas por los Rebeldes estos
buques fueron autorizados a atracar bajo
la vigilancia de la ONU
anteriormente el mecanismo de
verificación e inspección de la ONU para
yemen solo concedía autorizaciones para
determinados tipos de envíos ahora
entrega permisos para todo tipo de
envíos al puerto de aludida y si Dios
quiere esta medida facilitará la llegada
de buques En consecuencia del coste de
transporte de mercancías disminuirá
El regreso del comercio al puerto podría
ser una buena noticia para los géminis
ya el 80% de la población depende de la
ayuda humanitaria en las montañas del
Sur del país la única forma de
sobrevivir para parte de la población es
cortar árboles y vender la madera un
material que la gente usa para calentar
sus casas desde que el precio de la
energía subió
tengo que cortar árboles y venderlos
Para ganarme la vida no tengo ninguna
fuente de ingresos Aunque la
deforestación es un gran desastre nos
vemos obligados a hacerlo para tener
ingresos para vivir
Jiménez está atascado en una guerra
civil desde hace 8 años que deja cientos
de miles de Muertos las negociaciones
entre los Rebeldes y el gobierno central
están estancadas desde el fin de La
tregua el pasado 2 de octubre